we're going to begin with this as we
count down to earth day it's this friday
our earth 365 series is focusing on
issues affecting the health of our
planet year round now scientists have
long known the value of trees as vital
warriors in this fight against climate
change the new research shows the
world's forest helped cool the planet by
about two degrees which is a lot in
global terms for a store planet warming
carbon dioxide and cool the air helping
to prevent the droughts senior national
and environmental correspondent that's
ben tracy visited a unique research site
in northern minnesota scientists there
are learning more about these
potentially planet-saving ecosystems
which could help predict rising
temperatures
in the forests of northern minnesota
where winter often overstays its welcome
hidden among the trees is something
rather unusual
this is the marcel experimental forest
but you could just as easily call it a
climate change time machine
i mean this is such a unique place to
come to work
it's incredible each one of these is
giving you a manipulation
of what the future may behold david
weston is a senior scientist at oak
ridge national laboratory he and more
than 100 other researchers come here to
study how different degrees of global
warming might impact the world's
northern forests i noticed above the
door on the way in here it says welcome
to a warmer future
that seems kind of ominous it's giving
us some idea of how far we can push the
system and how resilient the system may
be it's absolutely amazing to have a
future scenario that you can measure
right now today
they pump heat and carbon dioxide into
these chambers the temperature
simulations range from no warming all
the way up to a frightening 9 degrees
celsius or more than 16 degrees
fahrenheit that's pretty extreme it is
extreme and so this is the upper end of
what we're trying to simulate and so at
this level of warming clearly this
doesn't react very well
no we're not doing very well here these
hexagon shaped chambers here at the
experimental forest are open to the sky
each one is more than 30 feet tall 40
feet wide and there are 10 of them here
on this massive seven acre site each one
providing a different glimpse
into the future and it's not just any
forest they're studying it's what's
known as the boreal forest the world's
largest forest system it wraps around
the upper third of the earth from north
america through scandinavia and much of
russia like some sort of planetary
headband
the hair or the bald spot exposed on the
top
and then you have this band that extends
around the forehead or the more curved
places on the globe stephen sebastian is
a researcher with the national forest
service he says the boreal includes
several species of trees and crucial
mossy peatland that play an outsized
role in regulating the earth's
temperature by sequestering
planet-warming carbon dioxide the
peatlands are only three percent of the
land surface area of the planet but they
hold up to a third to a half of the
global soil carbon pole
unfortunately what they're discovering
here inside these chambers is that the
hotter the planet gets the boreal forest
ecosystem dries out the critical peat
moss is eaten up by bacteria and
replaced by shrubs
that carbon once captured in the ground
is released into the atmosphere
accelerating the devastating impacts of
climate change
every single year has led to loss of
carbon
from these ecosystems that's the crisis
that we face taking a carbon from a
solid form in a stable form stored in
these peatlands to being a gas in the
atmosphere that's a greenhouse gas
and the real world impacts are already
painfully clear these drier northern
forests are now more prone to wildfires
record-breaking blazes tore through the
boreal forests of siberia in the past
two years
charring millions of acres and spewing
record amounts of carbon dioxide into
the sky
scientists say we need to quickly reduce
our planet warming emissions before
these four systems reach a tipping point
switching from accumulating carbon to
emitting it potentially even rapidly in
a so-called carbon bomb
in some ways this place is kind of a
giant warning
to humans about the future maybe it
gives us a reason to act
right i'm a bit of an optimist but why
roll the dice let's solve the problem
now
because the dire future foretold here in
this forest is one we can still change
for cbs mornings i'm ben tracy in north
minnesota
i like how he's thinking why roll the
dice i don't like rolling the dice on
anything especially when he says why
don't we solve the problem now yeah i
know it's the butterfly effect that ben
describes right the fossil fuels make
the planet hotter which in turn dries
out the force which in turn
you know
creates a hotter planet yeah and that's
where we are right now and if we can
just reduce those emissions maybe we can
save the planet we need those forests
it's not just climate change it's air
pollution now that's right right